[Music]
you are about to enjoy a free preview of
ron's gone wrong
[Music]
come on
yes hello so today mr takahashi pudowski
novelty exports international are very
excited to offer you this highly amusing
novelty the brother bouncy carmuck he
wiggles he bounces you get no he'll
he'll hold your phone
oh hi barney good day
uh
mr takahashi are you there hello mom did
you upload my router again i had tokyo i
need this contract
sure
it was fine
bunny
mr takahashi
to you
happy birthday to you
come on
that's it hey i'm yup yup happy birthday
dear dear barney
happy birthday to you
for
ta-da
lovely boy thanks gran
whoops
made with love and our own goat wolf and
from me
could it be wait for it is there any
possible way
wow
rock hammers you always did love your
rocks yeah i did always
used to
thanks dad and grant it's just you go
swollen my allergies no no no no the
podowski family had allergies what about
uncle boris he was possessed by a demon
in a cashew i don't know mom what time
your friends come bunny
i cook all day wow this real
bet your friends never had draped soup
before
like last time we had party remember
when you were sick
[Music]
all right
um
actually
the thing is
no one's coming
to the party
no one
you ask and all say no son
we're
we're a little worried about you
you never go out with anyone or have
friends over
you know that's that's why we thought
invite the whole class get the whole
gang over here right you know get you
the swing of things with everybody i
make food for all your buddies i don't
really have
you know
they probably just didn't read the
invite no one does paper these days they
send messages
with their bee bots really you need a
bee bot to have a social life these days
yeah dad kind of no i i don't want you
addicted to some device
you should be out there in the woods
kicking around with a buddy
get out there barn interact you don't
want to spend your whole life
glued to it
yeah though
[Music]
what it's just a craze and they cost a
fortune mm-hmm yeah
yeah you're right
it's a waste of money
no big deal
bubble delivery
what it can't be dad you were kidding me
i knew you wouldn't just give me rock
hammers i knew it
oh
um rock
[Applause]
[Music]
you get out of here
barney what's going on
it's okay dad really
these are great
getting something useful like a snow
shovel
or a cordless drill
it's what he really wanted
his mom were alive
she'd have known that
did they smell
mom people
[Music]
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait
no no no no no no
uh it's my son's birthday
i need a bee butt
hey baby just the basic model
no no no no no no hang on please
bloopers
i throw in goat goat for the bee pod
she's real friend and when you get bored
of this one
you can eat her let's waste good for
planet yeah
what no no no no no come on
three months wait what is this darnish
rasher i am not afraid of you bubble
bubble
[Music]
yeah what about that one ah that one
fell out of my fan earlier
[Music]
happy late birthday barney
dad
oh dad you got me one a real one this
time yeah i can see thank you thank you
thank you so much
hey if you hurry you can take it to
school
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
huh
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
seriously
come on come on
no what why
[Music]
[Music]
see what happens next order the entire
movie
ron's gone wrong now available rated pg
[Music]